[Música]
bienvenidos a reporteros el magazine de
los grandes reportajes de la redacción
de france 24 soy herminia fernández
comenzamos
el rápido avance del estado islámico en
2014 llegó a eeuu a incursionar en el
noreste de siria e irak desde entonces
los estadounidenses han trabajado
conjuntamente con las fuerzas de siria
democrática y el ejército iraquí para
recuperar el territorio que estaba en
control del estado islámico y luego para
luchar contra las células dormidas de
esa organización 8 años después los
aliados de eeuu tanto en siria como en
irak tienen razones suficientes para
desconfiar de washington un sentimiento
que se hizo aún mayor después de la
caótica retirada de afganistán sin
embargo a unos y a otros los que une el
temor que si eeuu deciden marcharse
la inestabilidad regrese a sus
territorios en irak es especialmente
evidente el miedo sobre todo en la
provincia de anbar donde irónicamente
los estadounidenses vivieron una de las
principales oposiciones después de la
invasión al país en 2003 nos acompaña
hoy catalina gómez nuestra corresponsal
en irán que se encuentra actualmente
cubriendo la guerra nuclear es la autora
de este reportero junto a ricardo garcía
vilanova catalina gracias por
acompañarnos quería comenzar
preguntándole la atención entre eeuu y
rusia es mayor por la guerra en ucrania
como conviven las tropas de estos dos
países dentro del noreste de siria y
cómo afecta a la población
ellas se tienen repartidos ciertos
sectores del territorio eso se hizo
especialmente evidente herminia cuando
el presidente de donald trump en el 2019
dice repentinamente que va a retirar a
las tropas y cerrar las bases que tenían
esa larga frontera con turquía en este
momento recordemos un avance de las
tropas turcas y de sus rebeldes aliados
estuvieron a punto de tomar toda esta
franja que es donde hay
mayoritariamente habitada por los puntos
pero también por otras minorías también
árabes y cristianos en aquel momento al
final el presidente de donald trump
decidió por mantener algunas tropas en y
se dividieron en los territorios y las
bases por ejemplo los rusos que no más
presencia en el área de la región de
jóvenes como los norteamericanos tienen
mayor presencia ya más cerca a la
frontera con irak y se cruzan haciendo
retenes en diferentes sectores de esta
región del este de siria realmente en
teoría coordinan estos movimientos de
garantizar los turcos no vuelvan a
entrar a este territorio sin embargo hay
bastante tensión de la cual es testigo
muchas veces la población de esta parte
decide ya si catalina estados unidos
sigue teniendo presencia en irak pero la
contradicción es que las regiones que
más se opusieron a la presencia después
de la invasión hoy son las que más piden
que no se vayan a que se debe esto
esto especialmente es evidente en la
provincia de anbar que limita concilia
se fue la provincia que más se opuso a
la invasión norteamericana en el 2003
una de las batallas más duras que se vio
fue la batalla de faluyá donde estuvimos
en este reportaje sin embargo hoy
piensan que si bien los norteamericanos
han hecho un gran daño al país y lo
destruyeron su presencia es necesaria
básicamente por el ascenso de esa y el
poderío de lo que llamadas fuerzas de
movilización popular de jan sabil esas
milicias que surgieron y que se hicieron
más potentes durante la lucha contra el
estado islámico que apoyaron que fueron
muy importantes dando apoyo al ejército
iraquí pero una vez acabado esta lucha
se convirtieron de cierta manera en un
gran problema para el estado iraquí
especialmente algunos sectores de
mayoría chiita algunas de ellas bastante
relacionadas con irán a las cuales
acusan de tener armas por fuera del
listado ellos terminan especialmente en
esas provincias
y que ellos puedan
atacarlos y tener muchísimo más poder en
estas regiones si se van los
norteamericanos gracias catalina veamos
la historia
[Música]
1700 familias viven en el campo eta las
ame desde octubre 2019 cuando el
presidente de donald trump ordenó
retirar las tropas y desmantelar las
bases estadounidenses construidas en el
noreste de siria para apoyar la lucha
contra el estado islámico
entonces más de 300.000 personas huyeron
de sus poblaciones cuando el ejército
turco y las facciones rebeldes aliadas a
turquía avanzaron hasta tomar el control
de una extensa región fronteriza que
había encontrado la estabilidad años
antes después de expulsar a isis y otros
grupos extremistas
muchos de ellos viven actualmente en
campos como este es el caso de salsa de
58 años que tuvo que dejar atrás todo lo
que tenía ambos que todo lo
rechazamos todo este desplazamiento de
la gente que no sabía dónde ir y nos
fuerzan a estar lejos de nuestra casa y
tierras y cuando trump dijo que se iba a
retirar sentimos como si se estuviera
burlando de nosotros
la caótica retirada de eeuu de
afganistán en agosto de 2021 recordó a
estas familias el sentimiento de
traición que habían sentido dos años
antes
bakú wood es uno de los pobladores que
ha dejado de creer en las promesas de
washington
cuando se fueron las mujeres y niños
lloraban los niños les preguntaban por
qué los iban a abandonar los americanos
son los líderes del mundo es la gran
nación del mundo
en 2014 y si se estuvo muy cerca de
tomar el control de cobán y un enclave
de mayoría kurdo fronterizo con turquía
el comandante char banda wish juró a los
hombres que defendió la ciudad
y venía a su tiempo entre pelear y
grabar con su cámara una batalla que
cambió de rumbo a favor de los kurdos
cuando la coalición internacional
liderada por eeuu decidió intervenir y
dar apoyo desde el aire
[Música]
en el momento de la lucha los americanos
no estaban en el terreno solo sucedió
meses más tarde cuando fuimos al
kurdistán iraquí y ya logramos con ellos
después de eso anunciamos la creación de
las fuerzas de sinatra en plática el 10
de octubre de 2015 luego mandaron un
pequeño grupo de americanos al terreno
en este entonces en un estado de
esta es la segunda vez desde que terminó
la batalla el comandante de davos visita
estas calles donde se libró la peor
parte de la lucha de todos los que
combatieron aquí son unos pocos
sobrevivieron a estos años de guerra
aquí solíamos dormir comer todo en este
lugar
después de tanto sufrimiento hoy la vida
de cobán está marcada por las
contradicciones el comandante no puede
usar su uniforme militar
los integrantes de las fuerzas de siria
democrática la coalición que lideró la
lucha contra el estado islámico en el
noreste de siria y que está integrada
por kurdos árabes y cristianos no tienen
autorización de operar en la ciudad como
consecuencia de un pacto hecho en 2019
entre rusia y eeuu con turquía desde
entonces deben permanecer a 30 km al sur
de la frontera desde el punto político
un político puede decir que éramos
socios trabajamos juntos nuestra
relación ha terminado eso puede pasar
pero para los combatientes para alguien
que pueblen esta guerra la idea es que
nosotros se lideramos juntos estas horas
teníamos una comunicación muy profunda
peleamos juntos en las mismas trincheras
como militar dejar a tu compañero botado
atrás en manos del enemigo es como
dejarlo solo frente a su vestido eso
como militar como persona es
extremadamente duro
después del caos que causó con su
anuncio inicial donald trump decidió
dejar en el este de siria alrededor de
900 hombres que tienen entre sus tareas
apoyar a las fuerzas desidia democrática
en la lucha contra las células dormidas
del estado islámico
pero desde entonces las fichas en el
tablero militar de esta parte del país
se reacomodaron el ejército de bashar
al-assad retomó el control de algunas
posiciones y los rusos y estadounidenses
garantizan que ni damasco turquía hagan
una nueva incursión
aún así las violaciones son constantes
esto es especialmente notorio en la
población de anaísa hoy convertida en
frente de batalla aquí campesinos como
abdollah txejo denuncian los ataques de
las fuerzas pro turcas
queremos que los americanos y los rusos
nos apoyen al menos con cohetes aviones
para que nosotros al menos sepamos que
tenemos apoyo que alguien nos respalda
si no hay alguien apoyándonos como lo
vamos a hacer con nuestra escala chicos
más de 12.000 mujeres y hombres de esta
región han muerto en la lucha contra el
estado islámico pero la historia de la
líder política kurda gervin haller es
diferente
[Música]
queda
una investigación reveló que el 12 de
octubre de 2019 fue asesinada por
hombres de agarrar al charquiya una
facción del ejército nacional sirio la
coalición de diversas facciones rebeldes
apoyadas por turquía el reporte médico
dictaminó que recibió 20 disparos y su
cuerpo fue abusado severamente le habían
amenazado muchas veces una vez le
dispararon en el carro le pregunté qué
le había pasado pero ella dio orden en
su conductor no decirme nada
el asesinato de jardín halal y la
captura de otras combatientes en
aquellos momentos confusos de 2019
aumentó el sentimiento de abandono entre
las mujeres cultas a las que tanto se
alabó por su valentía en la lucha contra
el estado islámico
muchas mujeres temen por su vida
una de ellas es esta jueza una de las
fundadoras del sistema judicial de la
administración autónoma del noreste de
siria que gobierna esta parte del país
ella tiene bajo su responsabilidad los
juicios relacionados con terrorismo
esconde su cara y pide no dar su nombre
porque tenía isis que ha declarado a los
jueces como objetivo militar
lo que me mueve a hacer esto son
historias como las de las ya civiles por
ejemplo el estado islámico las violaba
cien veces al día esto me motiva a
luchar por la defensa de los derechos
humanos y trabajar en el campo de las
mujeres la comunidad internacional tiene
la responsabilidad ética de estar con
nosotros en esta misión al menos en la
tarea de proteger a estas mujeres para
que no sean oprimidas
la lucha contra el estado islámico dejó
más de 10.000 prisioneros y más de
62.000 familias relacionadas con isis
recluidas en campos entre ellos hay
alrededor de 12.000 mujeres y niños de
60 países que es un gobierno se han
negado a repatriar
el hanal en el la copresidenta al
consejo ejecutivo de la administración
autónoma al noreste de siria y es quien
se encarga de las relaciones
internacionales
esto es un gran riesgo nosotros
compartimos toda esta información con
las naciones y compartimos con reportes
claro que todos los países de la
coalición están aquí y vean con sus ojos
lo que pasa ellos ven este gran riesgo
hay algunos países que repatriaron
algunos niños hasta ahora toda la
mentalidad es de patear a los niños pero
claro que esto no es suficiente se
llevan algunos niños pero llegan los
recién nacidos que los reemplazan
esta población a siria fronteriza con
turquía es otro ejemplo de la
complejidad de esta región donde las
minorías étnicas y religiosas temen por
su permanencia en estas tierras que han
habitado desde hace cientos de años
soporte inestable diversa por t inc
apoyar la estabilidad aquí apoyar la
democracia significa preservar todo esto
hasta hace pocos meses que no gabriel
que también esa sirio fue el portavoz de
las fuerzas de siria democrática como
muchos recrimina washington por no haber
evitado el ataque de turquía en 2019
pero también reconoce que la
intervención de eeuu y la coalición
acción fundamental en la lucha contra el
estado islámico y en la supervivencia de
estas poblaciones
finalmente la misión principal de la
coalición internacional es derrotar a
isis
esto no termina hasta que la crisis
siria esté finalizada y se alcance una
solución política
porque hice y principalmente surgen
tiempos de inestabilidad política tanto
en siria como en irak
políticael and stability bien serían de
irak
y
cruzamos a ir a donde esta mañana los
hombres del comando de la provincia de
anbar se preparan para ir al desierto y
buscar células del estado islámico
esta es una misión que realizan con
frecuencia
hoy las fuerzas de cuatro grupos
su misión es abarcar una extensa zona de
este gran desierto que se extiende hasta
las fronteras de siria arabia saudita y
jordania
por años esta ha sido una de las
regiones más peligrosas de irak
aquí las tropas estadounidenses
encontraron una de las mayores
oposiciones después de la invasión al
país en 2003 y donde el estado islámico
tuvo sus primeras bases en irak
no podemos dejar este lugar sin buscar
cada dos o tres días el comandante del
batallón de estas órdenes de revisar
toda esta área para no darle la
oportunidad a crisis de reagruparse
los insurgentes aprovechan las
complejidades geográficas del desierto
para escapar de la vigilancia del
ejército antes de isis al qaeda se había
escondido en estas dunas y cuevas
la seguridad actual se garantiza gracias
a estas patrullas pero también a la
vigilancia aérea que lleva a cabo la
coalición
la cooperación con la coalición es
particularmente especial en estos
desiertos ellos tienen tecnología
moderna y de vigilancia que les permite
filmar desde el cielo cuando se lo
pedimos
el ejército iraquí se desmoronó en 2014
cuando hice estuvo en control de un
tercio del país
miles de oficiales abandonaron sus
uniformes
eeuu que se había retirado de irak en
2011 regreso por invitación del gobierno
de bagdad
en la actualidad 2500 estadounidenses
permanecen para dar apoyo en aspectos
como vigilancia y entrenamiento pero las
últimas tropas que operaban en el
terreno abandonaron el país el 31 de
diciembre
el general nacional ganan es quien tiene
a su cargo la coordinación de estas
operaciones en la provincia de anbar y
al mismo se observa baja
el punto de vista lo son varios ha
cambiado mucho en el pasado los
habitantes no aceptaban la presencia del
ejército iraquí al igual que la de
fuerzas norteamericanas
los soldados iraquíes eran atacados en
las calles de anbar
en mi caso perdí a mi padre porque yo
ingresé a la academia militar pero la
situación ha cambiado
días después de la invasión el 28 de
abril de 2003 un grupo de habitantes de
faluyá protestó frente a este colegio
que los estadounidenses habían
convertido en un cuartel militar entre
los asistentes se encontraba el hermano
pequeño de abdul qádir de 13 años que
terminaría por ser asesinado
ellos no llevaban ni una piedra y los
americanos abrieron fuego directo
mataron alrededor de 28 personas y otras
16 quedaron a vidas
como en el noreste de siria las
contradicciones también están presentes
en irak a pesar del resentimiento y la
desconfianza un sector de la población
prefiere que los estadounidenses
permanezcan en el país este anhelos
especialmente imperativos de ciudades
como faluyá donde las tropas de eeuu
libraron las más duras batallas después
de la invasión nosotros rechazamos a las
fuerzas de ocupación pero debido a la
presencia de algunas facciones en el
país todavía necesitamos las fuerzas de
ocupación cuando el país esté
estabilizado y unido no necesitaremos
más a las fuerzas de ocupación
elche como tal fadawi tirar a la tribu
más grande de la región de anbar
como gran parte de la población sunita
del país que se había beneficiado de la
dictadura de saddam hussein el gobierno
hasta 2003 se opuso a la invasión de
eeuu y luchó contra su presencia
años más tarde terminaría cooperando con
los estadounidenses para luchar primero
contra al qaeda y más tarde contra y si
yo no digo que literalmente sean los
americanos los que tienen que darnos la
seguridad totalmente aunque también
podríamos pedirles apoyo al final lo que
buscamos es vivir en paz y nuestro
gobierno debe proveer a nosotros
en estos salones las críticas a eeuu no
son pocas los acusan de haber destruido
el país y de haber impulsado la división
sectaria
y
la razón por la que las fuerzas de
movilización popular existen ya terminó
tenemos un ejército completo y no las
necesitamos
pero hoy la gran preocupación de estas
tribus es el poder que acumulan las
fuerzas de movilización popular una
coalición que agrupa a las milicias la
mayoría de ellas chiítas que apoyaron al
ejército iraquí en la lucha contra el
estado islámico las acusan de tener
armas por fuera del control del estado y
seguir los intereses de irán
más de 650 hombres de la población de
saqlawiya están desaparecidos desde
julio 2016 durante la batalla para
liberar la población del control del
estado islámico en esta familia se
llevaron a todos los hombres mayores de
edad excepto a los ancianos
los pusieron en buses no sabemos quiénes
lo hicieron unos nos dicen que el
gobierno el ejército otros nos dicen que
de hezbollah
en algunas facciones de las fuerzas de
movilización popular las milicias que
apoyaban al ejército
una y otra vez vienen y nos dicen que
van a ser liberados que están vivos y
siempre pasa lo mismo no sabemos si es
verdad o no todos dicen algo diferente
estos hombres que protestan frente a la
llamada zona verde de bagdad hacen parte
de las milicias chiitas que tanta
desconfianza despiertan en la provincia
de anbar son ellos los que piden con
insistencia que las fuerzas
estadounidenses en marcha en
definitivamente del país el clamor se
hizo mayor desde que un drone
estadounidense asesino el comandante de
las fuerzas de movilización popular a
bonmatí al bus antes y al general y nani
casen suleimán y el 3 de enero del 2020
desde entonces estas milicias son
señaladas de llevar a cabo ataques
sistemáticos contra sedes que tienen
presencia estadounidense
más
desde la comunidad ya americana
después de la guerra contra el estado
islámico ámbar se ha convertido en la
provincia líder en proyectos de
reconstrucción en irak hoy las
autoridades de esta región se plantean
la posibilidad de crear una autonomía
que les dé independencia administrativa
y militar de bagdad el sheikh ali es el
hijo mayor del sheik ahmed y quien está
llamado a reemplazarlo
ahora mismo somos un país débil la
situación no es segura es crítica puede
explotar en cualquier momento las nuevas
generaciones como el sheikh ali creen
que una autonomía de la manera para
protegerse de una nueva inestabilidad en
irak
especialmente en este escenario cuando
eeuu busca reducir la presencia en la
región como ya hizo en afganistán
y poder
la mayoría de la gente aquí apoya esta
idea you can't de que ahora no se puede
tener relaciones que no operan bajo las
reglas del estado
para vivir en paz cada país necesita que
la gente siga las reglas
y es que el gran temor en la provincia
de anbar como sucede en el noreste de
siria es que otra retirada caótica de
eeuu termine por marcar trágicamente es
un extraño
hasta aquí reporteros de france 24
recuérdalo para sintonizar esta y las
misiones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima
[Música]